what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and i think it's about time for
another
demon slayer video as we got massive
news on demon slayer season two and we
got important updates on the movie
manga sales and more so make sure to
stay tuned for this one if you do enjoy
seeing demonstrator videos on this
channel and want to keep them coming
then show demon slayer some love by
smashing that like button
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future demonstrator videos
and while you wait for the next season
or video to drop feel free to check out
my growing demon slayer playlist where i
got videos about all the pillars
all the demon moons and all the demon
slayers among many more so make sure to
check that out
link in the description now without
further ado let's jump into it
so this will be an overall demonstrator
update video where we look at a number
of interesting updates
as you may know by now season 2 is not
referring to the movie even though the
demon slayer demon train movie or mugen
train movie
is a continuation of the season 1 tv
series
chronologically it will go season 1 the
movie and then season 2
another tv season down the line
somewhere they may break the movie up
into multiple episodes for rearings
but it is kind of funny that you can go
from season one to season two and it
won't make
sense because you're missing the crucial
contents of the movie nevertheless i'm
super glad that we won't have to wait
long for the entertainment district arc
possibly my favorite in all of demons
there and definitely top 2. but before
we break down
season 2 a bit more let's look at the
movie which was released on october 16th
and continued to break record after
record it had the best opening weekend
ever in japanese cinema history and went
on to become the highest grossing movie
in japanese theaters ever beating out
both japanese classics like spirited
away
and classics from the west like titanic
it's a huge win for us demon slayer fans
in particular and for anime fans in
general when you consider that a movie
based on a shonen anime series
can crush every other movie ever i keep
saying that anime is getting bigger and
bigger and this is definitely a sign of
that
and i'm glad to see it anime continues
to take over the world and demonstrator
one of my favorite series of all time
is definitely a good series to lead the
way right now according to wikipedia
demonstrator is significantly ahead of
spirited away in the japanese box office
having already grossed 37.49 billion
japanese
yen at the time of recording compared to
spirited away's 31.68
japanese yen figure so that was the
japanese box office and
if we look at the highest grossing anime
films worldwide on wikipedia
demonstrator has just passed spirited
away with a worldwide gross
395.7 million dollars
considering that it accomplished this
during these stay-at-home times and
before even releasing here in north
america is just
mind-blowing by the way for my north
american peeps we have been given a
vague release date of early 2021 so it
should be sooner rather than later and
i'll try to update you guys when i know
more about it
i really do want to be a part of this
historic moment especially as a huge
demonstrator fan so i plan to go see the
movie here in canada if possible
while taking all of the safety
precautions i can obviously
so that's the situation with the movie
the moog and train arc
is integral to understanding the story
for anime only
so you pretty much have to see it before
season 2 comes out and if you don't see
it in theaters then hopefully it'll be
available on funimation crunchyroll and
or netflix eventually so the transition
to
season 2 can be as smooth as possible i
definitely think that the success of
this approach will make other anime
series consider making canon movies that
serve as many seasons rather than just
making fun extra side stories into
movies as one piece and many other anime
have done
now let's turn to the demon slayer manga
sale something that impresses me
just as much as the movie sales the
original run before the anime premiered
was
3.5 million copies sold not too shabby
but where it gets absolutely crazy
is that since the anime premiered it has
sold over 150 million copies overall
meaning it sold about 50 million more
than attack on titan and 30 million more
than bleach according to wikipedia
that's how much difference an anime can
make in manga sales we all know how huge
and awesome attack on titan is i cover
it on this channel all the time and when
it comes to bleach most of us still
remember it
as being massively popular in its time
it was part of the big three after all
and yet demonstrate has crushed it in
sales already
despite the fact that bleach has way
more volumes
episodes and finished back in 2016.
currently demonstrator
is the 8th best selling manga of all
time and i have no doubt it will
continue to climb the charts as the
movie reaches the rest of the world and
the new seasons continue to drop
keep in mind it accomplished all of this
with just one season and a movie that
most of us in the west haven't even
gotten to see it
according to oricon in 2020 demonstrator
was by far the best selling manga
having sold 82.3 million copies
while second place was kingdom with 8.25
million
and third was one piece with 7.7 million
copies sold
to put this insane number into
perspective according to a useful reddit
post i'll link below
one piece the best selling manga of all
time had its best sales year in 2011
when it sold
almost 38 million copies so less than
half of what demonstrators sold in
2020. one piece is ongoing has sold over
480 million copies overall and has
98 volumes compared to demon slayer's 23
volumes
so one piece is still the goat in terms
of sales but that doesn't make all of
this any less mind-blowing for demon
slayer and honestly at this point
there's no telling where demon stare
sales will be
when the anime finally finishes airing
all of its seasons
for all these reasons i think a sequel
or spin-off is inevitable whether the
original mangaka works on it or whether
we have a kind of boruto sequel where
another mangaka takes over
but uses the demon slayer world to work
in the fact remains shonen jump loves
popularity and sales and keeps manga
going in its weekly magazine based on
popularity so there's no way
this is the end of the demonstrator
world despite the fact that the original
manga run
finished in 2020. that's my view at
least and the crazy thing is
when this sequel or spin-off eventually
comes out it will fuel even more sales
of the original manga so we do have a
potentially never ending cycle of hype
for demonstrator with all this
popularity it's no surprise that we got
news of a new season
season 2 which will cover the
entertainment district arc
another crazy thing to consider is that
despite the popularity of the first
season the story gets much better with
this season in my
view the first season continues to trend
daily on netflix who were
very wise to get it on their platform
you never know when seasons are going to
drop
on netflix but at least in japan the
second season of demon slayer has been
confirmed for 2021 aka for this year
there's no set date but hopefully we get
the movie
here in the west in the first half of
2021 and then we'll be ready to watch
the second
season during the summer or fall season
so as i mentioned this is one of my
favorite arcs
and we will get much better acquainted
with the sound pillar
we will meet new interesting demon
villains and there will be epic fights
including power upgrades
now i will go into the trailer and
probably mention some light spoilers at
this point
so if that bothers you feel free to
click away right now
so in the trailer we get a taste of the
entertainment district arc
we see a moving sash and a beautiful but
sinister looking woman the controlled
sashes are actually part of her demon
powers her name is daki
and she is very very attractive in the
manga so i hope that they do her beauty
justice in the anime arguably one of the
most attractive characters in manga
but maybe that's just me as i mentioned
we will also get significant power
upgrades for key characters so you can
look forward to that
as well as seeing what the sound pillar
is like and how powerful he truly is
we'll also get to meet his wives and
they're all great so you can look
forward to that
and that's probably all i'm gonna cover
here i don't want to give too much away
or tell you how the arc
ends in case you didn't read it yet but
i am here to pump you
up and tell you it will be absolutely
amazing
and i'm so glad that the same incredible
studio
ufo table or ufo table or whatever the
correct pronunciation is i'm so glad
they are back to make it this
is going to be so epic and if you just
can't wait to find out more about the
new season you can watch some of our
videos
like every demon moon and their powers
explain that every pillar ranked for
weak is the strongest which will most
likely answer most of your questions
links to those are in the description
but that is it for this video let me
know in the comments how excited you are
how you feel about demon slayer and if
you have any other interesting news or
questions about this epic story if you
do enjoy
seeing demonstrator videos on this
channel and want to keep them coming
then the best thing you could do
is smash that like button show demon
slayer some love and absolutely destroy
it
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future demonstrator videos
and while you wait for the next season
or video to drop feel free to check out
my growing demonstrator playlist where i
got videos about all the pillars
all the demon moons and all the demon
slayers
among many more topics so make sure to
check that out link in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one-tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
in grotto the world acquire respect but
they have a liam thompson al-jatal
cortman johnny boy draws emperor otaku
spidey life tinel baked buddhist and
tungsten tarkis and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers
angel cruz anatoly kozlovsky joe stanton
very gucci jessica kayla fond
rethuen de aura alicia actor bonnie
parks hinokami and water the red haired
raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games ted note head deadly saint matthew
cruz and anthony schreiber thank you all
so much if you do enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing epic people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life waifus and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link to that is in the
description
if you're interested you could also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully
already clicked so yeah you can support
more content that way if you prefer
whichever way you support us you can get
the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you